アメリカンドッグ
僕多分ここ最近一番食べている物がアメリカンドッグです
美味しい！
非常に美味しいんですけども 僕はここで
コンビニに売っているとほぼ100％アメリカンドッグ買います　はじめしゃちょーです
僕はそこで思ったわけですよ　アメリカンドッグどこのコンビニもほぼ100％アメリカンドッグが売っている
その中でどのアメリカンドッグが 一番美味しいのかってね
僕思った訳ですよ！という訳で主要なコンビニのアメリカンドッグ全部買ってきました
はぁー　本当に大変なんすよ
そのコンビニに今アメリカンドッグが売ってる訳もないからさ
よく集めたよこれだけ
コンビニの食べ比べシリーズあると思うんですけども
これねあのね撮るまでが大変だからね
オレ全部のコンビニ今日回ってきたからね　それも今出来立てだから
大変だったけどやりたかったんすよ
今午後の3時ですけど　まだ何も食べてません
食べずにアメリカンドッグを全部のコンビニ探して回った僕を褒めてください
まず出してみましょうか
はいという訳で各店舗の代表おち〇ぽ達に並んでいただきました
僕はこれからこのおち〇ぽをしゃぶ（カット
はいという訳で並んでいただきましたこちらの5本です
値段的にはね基本的に108円なんすよどこも
どこも108円なんだけどサークルKだけ120円だわ　サークルKだけちょっと高いみたいです
セブンイレブンのソース
こっちはローソンです
こっちはファミリーマート
サークルKだけこのパッチンってできないタイプです
ミニストップさんもコチラ
はい！はいはい！はい！この時点で一つ謎に気づきました
そう！アメリカンドッグのケッチャップ＆マスタード
サークルK以外全部キューピー株式会社
つまりサークルK以外のこのケッチャプは基本的に同じ？
サイズ的にはどこも一緒ですね
ローソンだけがちょっと
（アァァン）細長い感じで
あとは基本的に同じでございます
いや本当にアメリカンドッグめちゃくちゃ今はまってますからね
なんなんだろこのサクッとしたこの甘みの中に溢れるこのソーセージ
では早速食べ比べていきましょう！
まずはコンビニと言えばこちら
セブンイレブンでございます
良い色ですねこんがりきつね色に焼けております
デザイン、フォルム文句なし
たまらなき曲線美
衣もサクサクしており重みもしっかりあります
では参る
バッチリでございます
じゃあまずセブンイレブン
いただきます
うまい！（口を閉じようね）
うまいうまいうまい
衣が甘いです
ソーセージもしっとりしていてすごい食べやすい
なんでだろ・・・お腹減ってるからかな
めちゃくちゃ美味しいです
衣はサクサクというよりちょっとふわふわ系ですね
ちょっとミルキーなね優しい味わいが楽しめます
ごちそうさまでした
さすが王者というべきか
てかそもそものアメリカンドッグが美味しいわ
いやもうね・・・
もういいんじゃねぇかな
もういい感じにお腹が・・・否！
今回の動画ではアメリカンドッグのNo1を決める動画
必ず食べますからね全部
よっしゃ　次
はい　ローソンです
フォルム的には少し長細めであって
ちょっとカリカリ感が漂ってますね
あ、やべ被弾しそうだった
いただきます
うわああああ！
美味しい
あと生...生的な匂いがしました
生的ってなんだｗ
不思議な味わいでした
でも美味しいですね
ごちそうさまでした
なんだろう
やっぱアメリカンドッグ食べるとなんかこう
胸がね　なんか膨らむんすよ
いやそういう意味じゃねぇよ
そういう意味じゃねぇけどなんかこう
胸いっぱいになるというか幸せな気持ちになります
うまい！
ローソンはね結構このギュッと濃縮してて
パクッ、グッうまい！
好みの問題ですね
ふんわりしたやつをハフっと食いたいならセブン
バグっと食いたいならローソンです
なんの説明にもなんねーな
ファミリーマートのアメリカンドッグです
結構ずっしり系ですね
シバかれた跡が残っております
まあファミリーマートのアメリカンドッグは
なんと言ってもこちらですね
当たりが出たらもう一本貰えると
下品だな
当たりが出てほしい
いただきます
美味しいよ
あ・・・。
お腹いっぱいかもしんないなー(-_-;)
いや美味しいよ　美味しいと思う
けど正直今のオレにはわかんねー
お腹いっぱいなんだもん！
ごちそうさまでした
腹が...腹が...腹がいっぱいです
いや美味しいよ！
次いきましょう次
サークルK...あー腹いてぇーわマジ
サークルKサンクスのアメリカンドッグです
唯一キューピーの呪縛から解放されしこのケチャップとマスタード
果たしてどのようなテクニックを見せてくれるのでしょうか
実に開けずらい
ここは、double bending systemを採用してほしかったところでございますが
マスタードが出ない
（この時私は感じた...
（これを作った人は...天才だ）
まぁまぁ、こうなっちゃいます
あーーー！！！
あーーーーー
なんじゃこりゃーーー
お腹いっぱいだよー
味がわかんないよ
あーーー⤵
ごちそうさまでした
味がわかんない（泣）
ちょっと5本は多かった
次！
ミニストップのアメリカンドッグです
美味しそうな匂いがしますね
最後だこれを食えばどのアメリカンドッグが一番美味しいかがわかる！
やるしかねぇだろ
ラスト
ミニストップのアメリカンドッグ　いただきます！
あーー⤵
ごちそうさまでした
はい　という訳で5種類のアメリカンドッグ食べ終わりました
格付けといきましょう
最初に食べたから美味しかったです
おめでとうございまーす
二番目に食ったていうのが大きかったっすね
美味しくたべれました
他の3つです　おめでとうございます